[موسيقى]
ما ان يقترب موعد اذان المغرب حتى تضج هذه
الحاره كما مختلف احياء القبه في طرابلس
بحركه تبادل للاطباق التي يحملها الكبار
والصغار من باب الى باب عاده رمضانيه
تراثيه يحافظ عليها الاهالي هنا رغم ضيق
الحال
[موسيقى]
على طول عنا شيء اسمه السكبه يعني نحن
بنوزع الاكله اللي نحن بنعملها بالبيتنا
نحن بنبعث منها صحن صغير لجارتنا وكذلك
الامر جارتي ما بتردلي الصحون فاضيين هي
جارتي شو عامله بترجع كمان بتبعث لي سكبه
صغيره بتكون السفره تنوعت عندي ولا عند
جارتي ولا عند اي حدا وكل واحد حسب
الظروفه حسب وضعه حسب طبخته وشفته هلا
الاوضاع كيف بس الحمد لله قصيتنا مكملين
وربنا ميسرها ورزقنا فيه
[موسيقى]
كانت طبختي اليوم بس لوبيا ورز بس رمضان
كريم والناس بتكون هيك كمان كريمه كمان
بهذا الشهر الفضيل مرت خالي بعثت لي
المعكرونه ببندوره هون من عند مرت عمي من
عند سلفتي ومن عند جارتي وانت اللي شايفين
[موسيقى]